l'agent de merde a mis ceux-là de cette façon désolé
messieurs la police n'utilise que le
frère de Tampa [ __ ] c'est bon dans ce cas j'ai besoin de
voir les badges nous sommes à la retraite du
travail et maintenant nous faisons la sécurité car je
suis pour un groupe de rock appelé striper d'accord
jamais  encore une fois, un oppresseur va-t-il envahir les
gens, mais maintenant je continue à me laver, c'est
le gars que les gens disent que le rock chrétien
craint c'est que ouais personne je veux dire ce que font les
connards ouais ouais je euh je l'ai compris
tournée de réunion à Jérusalem oh
et ils ont besoin d'une sécurité supplémentaire, regardez, je
souhaite que nous n'ayons pas à y aller, mais
comme vous le savez, ce n'est pas le monde
dans lequel nous vivons maintenant frère si vrai hmm alors que puis-je
faire pour nous  à la recherche de marchandises
pour choquer et capaciter et emprisonner notre
prochain d'accord sérieusement nous allons
laisser ça juste je l'ai fait avant d'appeler
alors allez Jesse ne veut pas dire que les gants
me frappent frappez-moi allez faites-le hé moi hé
non  sans difficulté, pas de succès